[Applause]
[Music]
hey there everybody
let's have a little fun with this one
this is a video that i've had the idea
of for a very long time and it was a
while before i actually sat down to just
write the dang thing out i had to come
out
wow i didn't have to i decided to come
up with
my list of the top 10 best
disney villains a little bit about
my parameters here i did decide to go
only with anime now
disney has made plenty of live-action
movies over the years some of which even
have phenomenal villains
judge doom from roger rabbit comes to
mind although partially animated but
anyways
i opted not to do this because generally
when you say
disney villain or really even disney
movie
generally people mean the
animated canon and i am sticking to
disney animated i am not counting pixar
even though
disney now owns them i still deal with
them as a
separate thing so let's talk
about my own personal top 10 that i'm
sure
everyone will agree with
right
number 10 cruella de vil
let's start this list off with a bit of
class question mark i
just love the pomposity of cruella de
vil
i love the self-obsession i love the
complete lack of self-awareness
she's just absolute over-the-top
but in a way more scaled-down way the
top villains are pretty common in disney
but what i like about cruella is she's
over the top
but not trying to conquer the world not
trying to take over a kingdom
not you know doing these grand schemes
she just wants a coat with spots
it's just so small and she's willing to
be
so awful in order to get it
like the song
[Music]
i know she doesn't sing it but i can't
think of her without thinking of the
song so
that helped
number nine king candy
aka turbo from wreck-it ralph
so this is the one that is the most
recent that is going to make this list
because it's been noted by
lots of people with much bigger
platforms than me
that disney recently has kind of
de-emphasized the villains
and has favored what one would consider
to be the surprise villain
and that's not to say that that sort of
thing doesn't work i would actually
argue that that has worked
very well in some cases but
it does mean that the villain doesn't
get the chance to be
big operatic fun and memorable the way
they are
in earlier disney films i do feel like
king candy is the exception to this
because he is a memorable character
even prior to the reveal of him being
the villain
if you were going to criticize villains
specifically a lot of the surprise
villains in recent years
have been fairly unremarkable characters
until you found out that they were
villains
and i also like that it's not a turn on
a dime
you learn as it goes along something's
up with this guy
something's off the pieces start to fall
together and then the final reveal of
him
as being turbo as someone who has taken
over a game who has basically done what
ralph
tried to do but did it with absolutely
none of the moral quandaries that ralph
has developed as he's gone along
and then the final image of him as this
big monster i think which is another
gamble
replacing your villain with effectively
a monster more often than not doesn't
work
because you're invested in the humanoid
version of them but in this case it
works because
it's the exact same face the vocal
delivery is the same
oh that
number works hades
this easily is the most
fun villain on the list i mean look lots
of these villains are fun
and that's sort of the mark of a of a
good disney villain is that you
usually are fun but hades i mean he
makes the movie
he is easily the best thing about it and
the performance of the
snappy it's almost sort of used car
salesman
approach of just being the name is hades
lord of the dead hi how you doing
quick and bantering cutting deals as
opposed to being all
booming you know i am a 80s hey i'm
hades how you doing
it's just great it undercuts what you
would expect from a villain who is the
lord of the underworld
and it just plays so well it is the
antithesis of what you would have
expected but yet still
works villainous it's just so fun
number seven judge frollo
i have to slightly confess something i
have not actually seen
the hunchback of notre dame from start
to finish yet
i have however because i've heard such
good things about for a little isolated
his scenes and took a look at him
basically in a vacuum
and i see why the guy is highly praised
as a villain
he is arguably one of the most
monstrous villains in the disney canon
but he thinks he's righteous
he thinks he's the good guy and that's
actually something that i don't think
any of the other villains on this list
have
and it's actually very uncommon in
disney by and large as i mentioned with
these
villainous terms part of what makes them
fun is they know they're the bad guy
and they just revel in it and i do love
that but there's something to be said
for someone so misguided as to be
so monstrous as frollo is
and to think that they're the good
person in this scenario
it's chilling his song especially
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
not messing around
number six one that i think a lot of
people
probably would have put closer to the
top than me
but like understand coming up with my
top 10 was not
super hard ordering it was
so give me some leeway on that
maleficent the queen
of evil definitely knows she's bad
rebels in it and she is
just owning it top to bottom from the
look
to the way she delivers her lines to
that laugh
and again an instance of becoming a
monster at the end this case the dragon
that does actually work i think part of
it being that the dragon
is so stylized in a way that you feel
like you still feel her presence within
it
even though it doesn't look like her
anymore plus you know i don't think they
got
would have gotten away with throwing the
sword through a woman's chest but
dragon oh yeah oh yeah take her down how
completely she embodies the
evil oh it's good and
look the live action maleficent angelina
jolie did good work i didn't see the
sequel i don't think anybody did
but um this is still my preferred
version of maleficent
number five professor
radigan from the great mouse detective
i like his design i like how
intimidating he is especially when he
rears back because often
because he's talking to characters who
are so much shorter
than he is he's frequently sort of
hunched over them
but every now and then he sort of rolls
his shoulder back and you realize how
much
bigger he is than everybody else in that
film
but then what really puts it over the
top is the vocal performance
finish it flabby
i love it vincent price
he went on record as saying this was one
of his favorite roles he ever got to
play and you can
hear it in every line delivery
because vincent price reveled so much in
playing this part it means that radigan
revels so much in evading
outwitting and just taking on
the hero he has a personal thing where
he just
wants to mess with basil and
whenever something doesn't go his way oh
he cracks and you can see it this harsh
turn
and again still really fun but also
taking advantage of his visual design
the confrontation at the end
and again this is something that could
have really gone south because
so far it's been a battle of wits and
it's going to end with a
fight that shouldn't work part of what
it does
is he's kind of terrifying at the very
end between the claws and like his
clothes get ripped and the
look in his eyes oh
it's a great turn it's a great climax to
a great character
number four lady tremaine
aka the evil stepmother from cinderella
no big plans no grand scheme
not even really a clear discernable goal
that is in opposition to the heroes
just doesn't want to see the hero
succeed
she is just so focused on herself
and her own daughters and has no
interest
cinderella having anything
but that's not even necessarily like a
goal in her life i don't think she makes
it a
mission to make cinderella's life
miserable
but she does still do it and she does
enjoy doing it
and a lot of this one
is actually just in the i'm going to say
performance but i
by mean visually the body language
the look the eyes the way they narrow
she figures things out puts pieces
together
decides on the next cruel thing she's
going to put
cinderella through in many ways she is
the most believable villain
because while i've never had a parental
figure
like lady tremaine i have met people
like her
and they're terrifying i'm so she
before we get to the top three i do want
to do a quick rundown of honorable
mentions some
great characters that for one reason or
another didn't quite
make the list but i still want to shout
out all the same
we have shir khan was so smooth with his
voice
and it's just so suave and almost sort
of
endearing until suddenly he's really not
dr facilier that voice and i
love the scheming nature of him and that
ultimately he's just trying to
save his own neck at the behest of these
other forces that he's cut deals with
takah i love taka i love
to death the final reveals about taka
however the reason takai didn't make the
list is because
ultimately it's more of an obstacle than
it is a real proper villain
long john silver i really wanted to put
him on here because i think
treasure planet is so underrated as a
film
and i think this is a terrific rendition
of long john silver but like
so many versions of treasure island
it's debatable how much of an outright
villain he
is isma she almost made this list
she was really close much like hades she
is just a lot of fun with a terrific
performance from earthquake basically it
came down to her and cruella for that
number 10 spot and cruella
just edged her out but oh it was close
mcleach from rescuers down under another
movie that i think is just flat out
underrated
as a film and george c scott gives such
a good performance as this character
but ultimately as much as i like him i
couldn't in the good conscious put him
above the ones who actually made the
list
murloc i have a lot of fond memories
about this villain from the ducktales
movie but i do
have to admit that upon rewatch he has
played for last more often than i
remember
i think in a lot of ways he's hired my
mind because of what he transforms
into towards the end of the movie which
is awesome the headless horseman
again kind of debatable just because of
the nature of the horsemen
and sort of how you feel about the story
overall but i'll tell you
there's just something for me so i it's
one of my favorite
laughs and film of all time just rearing
back
holding the jack-o-lantern and the sword
and
laughing
[Applause]
it's so good and last honorable mention
goes to chernabog
who honestly could have made the list
the only reason he doesn't is because
even if you're going to make an argument
that he is a villain it's only in one
segment
of a film that does not have a coherent
storyline
because it's fantasia just doesn't as
much as i love him and i
love the knight on bald mountain segment
he's not actually a functional villain
for what that movie is so let's get to
our top
three
[Music]
scar from the lion king
again a lot of it comes down to vocal
performance and
you know doubly so now that we've had
the comparison
with the um photorealistic remake but
jeremy irons just
drips personality and
venom the lines that he and again can
turn
so quickly he can be sarcastic he can be
almost a little flamboyant and then
he'll just go
cold in the face and go kill him
it's chilling it's really
really good
number two is gaston
i like gaston because again he does not
have this huge ambition of
power or revenge
he's just entitled
he thinks because he is strong
and handsome the world is supposed to
bend to his
will he is i'm just going to say it
he is toxic masculinity personified
and it is the perfect
villain for a story about somebody as
empathetic and intellectual as
belle and as someone whose entire
journey is about
coming to better understand that he has
to change
and he has to better understand other
people to care about other people as the
beast gets on
is the perfect counterpoint to all of
that
because it's so much deeper than just
the surface of oh
the horrific beast looking thing is
really a guy and the handsome looking
guy is really monster yes there is that
but it goes
so much deeper gaston thinks
the world owes him what
he wants he has never questioned that
he never will question that even if he
hadn't
died and he is a really
terrific villain especially for the
story he's put in
but he does not quite make it
my number one spot it may be nostalgia
partially speaking here but i have to
give my number one slot
to ursula the sea witch ursula
is everything that i ask for
in a disney villain she has a
terrific design has a boisterous
and just flamboyant
vocal performance she has a terrific
song
and she is driven
and she is heartless and
she enjoys twisting
the knife and she's also intimidating
i know she turns big and huge at the
very end and that does work
but honestly for me it's that shot
when she transforms from the human body
she's been masquerading as
into the sea witch that that
is ursula that is what i want in
a disney villain and just
oh you poor unfortunate souls
you had no idea what was coming for you
she's my favorite but who's yours
whatever it is drop something on down in
the comments let's talk about it since
this video doesn't have a sponsor
i wanted to highlight another creator in
this case
princess weeks who you might know from
her collaborations with lindsey ellis
for its lit
for pbs but i actually wanted to
highlight her own personal channel
molina pendulum where she makes her own
amazing video essays she did a really
fantastic breakdown
of gone with the wind a few weeks ago
and i would highly recommend checking
out her channel
whole bunch of stuff to do as well
usually like subscribe share this around
i have a patreon which is
really important it is actually how i'm
paying my bills at this point
so i helps keep the lights on but
you don't have to end of the day
you are the council and i just run the
meetings
and until next time this council is a
[Music]
jerk
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
um
[Music]